thanks for joining us America in the
lobby of Ramsay Solutions Derek and
Bridget are here hey guys how are you
good how are you
welcome welcome good to have you how
much dad have you paid off one hundred
and twenty seven thousand three hundred
$19.50 excellent where are you guys from
Tampico Illinois cool what are you doing
for a living
I'm a machinist and I'm an insurance
agent cool very cool and how long did it
take you to pay off 127 grand 20 months
Wow
that's quick making what kind of money
we started out at 82,000 and ended at a
hundred and two thousand one hundred two
thousand yeah way to go you guys are
killing it great so what kind of debt
was the 127 a couple cars student loans
and also our house oh you paid off your
home we did
you're officially weird I know the grass
is wonderful no mortgage I love it well
congratulations you two very well done
how old are you guys I'm 29 and I'm 27
and you have a paid-for house yeah and
what's this foul spot worth about a
hundred thousand way to go you guys
congratulations man you got the world on
fire right now you're making a hundred
grand a paid four hundred grand house
life is good you're not even 13 yes it
is Wow excellent excellent so what
started this journey 20 months ago how
this come about we had a little bit of
we were pregnant with her what we
thought was gonna be our first kid we
unfortunately lost the baby and during
that time a lot of things really set in
for us yeah just it kind of scared us
and we weren't we're now we're near
financially ready for that and then just
kind of scared us and like you say we
got sick and tired of being sick and
tired afterwards yeah so we we decided
to find something to do the cleaner so
clean it up and get it better so yeah
Wow very cool so that kind of set you on
the course of going okay
hey that was an awful thing to go
through but it makes you reset and
relook at everything doesn't it yes yes
very cool fun fun so you decided to get
out of debt then what happened
we started cleaning up the debt we were
on fire her gizelle intense as you say
and we knocked out around forty five
thousand dollars in our first fifteen
months Wow but then unfortunately
disaster I guess struck and Bridgette
lost her brother in a car accident in
January of this year oh my good he was
fortunate or he was nice enough to think
of us when he yeah
before he passed and he helped us come
along and finish up the debt this year
with that gift that he left us oh my
goodness so we he had a life insurance
policy that we had no idea about and he
he loved that for us and actually the
way that I kind of went down we had had
a discussion with him about a year ago
about Dave Ramsey and Total Money
Makeover and we were getting out of debt
and he was not the kind to have payments
on cars or anything like that he had
plenty of toys but he wrote out a check
for him he paid cash and so he was so
proud of what we were doing and we
talked to him at Christmas about how you
know we wanted to pay off our house and
what our timeline was he thought at that
time that we were crazy but he came into
my office on New Year's Eve of this past
year and to let me know that he had paid
off his house because we inspired him 15
days later we lost him in the car axle
so little did we know he had actually
taken out the policy about six months
before he passed away so you know we we
don't know if the reason why he took it
out was because of this conversation we
had with him but you know he he knew we
were getting on the right track and for
sure you put your beneficiary down yeah
sure that was because he was proud of
the direction you're going
mm-hmm because he was in the same way
himself oh my goodness so he definitely
left a legacy
Wow and then he also he was a farmer as
well and he left us his land too so yeah
he must have been single very single as
a friend of mine says single Isabella
bill oh my goodness Wow Wow
well I'm so sorry y'all went through
this horrible tragedy but what a
wonderful way that he says he's proud of
you and you've got that to hold on to
forever as part of this whole legacy you
know he's made it so we have a 7 month
old daughter and and you know he's made
sure that she's she's gonna be all right
we're all gonna be all right so and left
almost a legacy oh wow that's poignant
you guys have been through a lot of ups
and downs yeah but you really and so
really what ends up happening is is you
have this extra level of nobility to do
something really smart from this point
forward yes there's this call on you
this this mission that you mean you just
can't disappoint this yeah there's a
story you know it's not an option you
have to go forward now yeah Wow well
congratulations I'm very proud of you
and obviously he was too so very very
neat all right Derek and Bridget from
Illinois 127 thousand dollars paid off
in 20 months making eighty two to a
hundred and two count it down let's hear
a debt free scream three two one
I love it I love it
Wow heartbreaking and inspiring all at
the same time Wow Wow Wow
Oh